the central limit theorem is absolutely
remarkable it is a very deep result and
highly non-trivial and non-intuitive
there's no apparent reason why this
random variable here a standardized
version of the sum of random variables
should have an approximately normal
distribution furthermore it is very
useful and one key reason is that it is
universal it doesn't matter what the
distribution of the X's is no matter
what the distribution is still in the
limit this standardized version of the
sum is going to behave like a normal
random variable and if we wish to apply
it to particular examples or models the
only thing that we need to know about
the distribution of the X's are the
corresponding means and variances as
we're going to see in multiple examples
when we apply it it turns out to be very
accurate and it is also a very nice
computational shortcut even if we knew
in detail the distribution of the XS in
order to calculate the distribution of
SN we would have to take the
distribution of the axis and convolve it
with itself and times something that can
be computationally tedious who are as
the computations that are involved when
we use the central limit theorem are
very very simple as the example that
will be coming up will show to us
finally at the philosophical level the
central limit theorem justifies why
models involving normal random variables
are very natural whenever you have a
phenomenon or an object that's affected
by multiple noise sources and if these
noise sources are independent then the
overall effect of those noise sources is
going to be well modeled by a normal
random variable even if the distribution
of each one of these noise sources is
very different from being normal
and this is a reason why in many many
applications in many different fields
normal random variables provide very
useful and accurate models since the
central limit theorem is so useful and
important it is worth making sure that
we understand exactly what it sells and
to make a few comments on its
mathematical content what it says is the
following we take the sum of independent
identically distributed random variables
we form this standardized version of the
sum where we subtract the mean and
divide by the standard deviation of the
sum and then what it tells us is that
the CDF of this random variable Zn
converges to the normal CDF so what we
have is a statement about CDF it does
not yet tell us anything specific about
PDFs or pmfs
so for example if SN and the axes are
all continuous random variable so Zn is
also continuous you might wonder whether
the PDF of Zn converges to a normal PDF
it turns out that there are results of
this kind that assert convergence of the
PDF or even PMF of this random variable
to a normal PDF in some sense but these
results generally need a few more
mathematical assumptions for the results
to be valid nevertheless when we saw
pictures of various examples we will do
this by showing pictures of PDFs and
pmfs because these are easier to
visualize now since the result is so
general and so important
it might be worth understanding to what
extent it can be generalized to other
contexts our main two assumptions are
that the random variables are
independent and identically distributed
can we remove those assumptions there
are versions of the central limit
theorem that apply to the case where the
x i's are not identically distributed
one just needs
make certain assumptions on the means
and the variances of the excise some
conditions will be needed
also the assumption of Independence does
not need to be literally true there are
versions of the central limit theorem
that are valid when we have just weak
dependence that is nearby X's may be
dependent but if you compare x5 with X
of 1 million then these two random
variables are essentially independent in
those cases we can still apply a
suitable version of the central limit
theorem and finally you may be curious
how this result is proved one way of
proving it which is the way it was
originally established a long time ago
for the special case of Bernoulli random
variables X in which case s is binomial
the way it was established was by
carrying out algebraic manipulations on
the binomial formulas but this was a
derivation that would not generalize for
the general case the proof is obtained
using so-called
transform methods which is a topic that
we are not covering but it goes as
follows we consider this function of the
random variable Z n where s is some
parameter and we show that this
expectation converges to the
corresponding expectation if you have
the standard normal Z in the place of Zn
and that this is true for all s or at
least for all s in some rich enough set
and then one appeals to some deep
mathematical results that tell you that
if this kind of expectation converges to
that expectation then the CDF of Zn must
also converge to the CDF of Z but this
is a proof that involves various steps
and appeals to some deep results from
other fields of mathematics and finally
there is the practical side what exactly
does it say and
do we use it since the CDF of Zn can be
approximated by the CDF of a standard
normal this means that in practice we
can treat the random variable ZN just as
if it were a standard normal but now we
notice that SN is obtained as a linear
function of ZN namely the definition of
ZN gives us this formula so SN is a
linear function of ZN if we pretend that
ZN is normal and since linear functions
of normal random variables are normal
this means that we will also pretend
that SN is normal so in practice the way
to carry out calculations is often to
just pretend that SN is normal with the
appropriate mean and variance these are
the correct means and variance of SN and
that's the only information that we need
in order to apply it if we know mu and
Sigma squared and using the normal
approximation then we have an
approximate distribution for SN and we
can go ahead now in practice can we use
the central limit theorem when n is
moderate for example if n is 30 can you
apply the central limit theorem this is
a relation that's true in the limit of
very large n how large should n be it
turns out that the central limit theorem
gives us very good approximations even
when n has moderately small values now
this approximation sometimes will be
better and sometimes worse it helps if
the distribution of the X's that you're
starting with has some common features
with the normal distribution if the X's
are already normal then s will be normal
and there's no approximation involved if
the X's are close to normal then for
fairly small values of n S will be very
well modeled by a normal random variable
now what does it mean that the
distribution of the X's looks a little
bit like the normal one it helps if the
distribution is
symmetric around its mean and it also
helps if it is unimodal in the sense
that it has a single peak rather than
multiple peaks